i'm a misanthrope yet
i am utterly benevolent i have more than
one screw loose yet i am super idealist
who
digests philosophy more efficiently than
food who said these words well it was
none other than alfred nobel
the subject of this wonderful new book
by my friend uni turatini called
betraying the nobel
and in this episode you're going to hear
about all sorts of amazing tidbits that
you never knew about the nobel prize
the prize as it was known the nobel
peace prize
including why donald trump was a good
selection
according to uni perhaps and that one
that alfred himself may have
condoned if you will if you can believe
it you'll also hear about why is the
nobel peace prize
which is a swedish organization alfred
nobel was swedish why is it given out in
norway
that's kind of weird i always perplex me
and you'll also hear about what can be
done
to restore the nobel peace prize to
their former
statue stature of glory prestige etc
that they had for many many years and
some say the gold of the nobel peace
prize has become
tarnished thanks to being awarded to
individuals that we discuss in this
episode so for now
everything you've ever wanted to know
about the nobel peace prize coming up
in betraying the nobel with none other
than uni turatini enjoy the episode
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
all the way from are you in oslo right
now oni i'm in oslo
norway absolutely yeah the home of the
nobel peace prize
and she has written a phenomenal new
book
a uh a book that was a cree de cor a cry
from the heart as they say
that really just struck me so deeply and
touched uh
many nerves and in a good way uh and i
couldn't be more proud to become
friendly with uni as she's come
to bring this book to the world that so
desperately needs it
and the book is of course i'm only
holding up my early version of it
but it's called betraying the nobel and
i want to welcome you uni
all the way from norway thank you so
much for joining us on the into the
impossible podcast
thank you so much for having me brian
it's an honor and it's funny you're
you're holding up the the previous cup i
don't even know how that went yet like
yeah so i have not actually not seen or
held my book
wow i get i get mine uh tonight uh from
amazon
i'll get it in the kindle form first and
then i'll get it in physical copy they
assure me tomorrow
which is publication day and it's
published by pegasus and it's a
beautifully
uh it's a beautifully written book it's
a very uh
it's a very very quick read i read it
literally
in under two or three hours non-stop
which is saying a lot for
the pandemic podcasting that i'm doing
i'm reading trying to read
a book every week or two weeks and this
one just kept me up i couldn't stop
reading it
oh thank you brian thank you for that
yeah
yeah it's so wonderful so i want to talk
to you first and foremost
about uh about what it's like to write a
book like this and
why you were inspired to do this you you
are aware of my book losing the nobel
prize which is about science and kind of
my personal experiences with the nobel
prize and
and some of its shortcomings that myself
and other members the scientific
community have highlighted
uh to some avail not necessarily no
avail but why did you
a an author who had previously written
about the lone wolf killer uh
and and has done so much in so many
other fields
why did you write a book about the nobel
prizes
yeah you know that's it's it's a great
question um
i have all as in a region myself i've
always been
very proud and honored that my home
country of norway gives out the nobel
peace prize
and um i thought you know we were doing
such a great job and then
in 2009 when they awarded barack obama
and before he had i mean he had when he
was nominated he had been less than two
weeks in office
and he had you know given a lot of great
speeches but he hadn't really started
doing
any of the things that he said he would
do so
obviously that price was given for
his potential as a leader and what he
would do
than for what he actually had done and i
thought i was curious so
that actually sparked an interest to dig
deeper and you know you're asking like
my what
my reason i i love research so i i'm
curious
as you know in in general about a lot of
things
and my first book on the on the lone
wolf killers
is really about how our culture how our
communities
contribute to someone's evolution into
becoming
a mass killer and so
i discovered that the nobel peace prize
is also a lot about culture
and who wins is a lot about the
norwegian culture and
norwegian politics and you know what i
found was you know that
the committee there's a committee of
five people
and they are all politicians either
you know now they're all former
politicians
uh they're not active any longer but
they have given the honor to
to sit on the nobel peace prize
committee as a thank you
for a long and loyal service to the main
you know
the two main political parties so
obviously then
the decisions that they make the
selections that they make
are political and that's what i found
and
that you know really shocked me
and when uh you approach a book like
this your previous book
you have uh you're not trained as a
journalist you were
trained as a as a lawyer or to study law
can you talk a little bit about your
background and
what makes you such a good storyteller
um
well i'm not sure that i'm a good
storyteller but
i yeah i studied law in three countries
uh
i'm a lawyer in norway and then i also
summoned telling
at the same time as i was finishing up
my my studies in norway i studied law in
paris
and so i have a law degree uh from from
france as well
and then i did a master's uh in law
in boston in the united states and
um took the new york bar exam so um i
practiced
as an attorney of law in a in a
in a u.s law firm in paris back then and
i
and i worked from some for some
companies as an in-house lawyer as well
and in the finance industry so i come
from a very sort of
legal um corporate world
and um
and that was never really a passion i
mean i did it as i thought that was you
know something i was supposed to do i
mean i
and what i did what i loved about my law
studies though
is that you know i got to do a lot of
research i so i got to sort of explore
my curiosity
why things work the way they do in
society and you know all these things
um but practicing corporate law was not
really
uh my passion so um but i've always been
a ferocious reader i mean like
yourselves i've always been very curious
so um so you know this from but but from
doing research
and finding out you know finding
information
and then to writing this book i mean
that was uh that was a longer
process you know so that took me some
that was the learning curve
for sure and still is you know so yeah
well you're definitely meticulous in
your research and
when we chat more in the future i'll ask
you about that process
as coming from a lawyer's perspective
because i think you bring
some of that kind of cross-examination
that rigor that
mental rational way of thinking that's
really scientific
about a a peace prize which is uh which
is just uh phenomenal
i want to get controversial uh for a
second i read a quote from you
in a in an august newspaper actually
i've just found out that it has the
highest set fourth highest circulation
uh newspaper in the united states and
that's called the new york post from my
hometown new york
uh and the following quote comes from
author uri uh
trump president donald trump is actually
exactly what the alfred nobel wanted for
his peace
champions can you explain that to me
and uh was that taken out of context
and when i you know i last week just a
week ago
i was interviewed by the new york post i
knew they wanted to do a feature
of my book um coming out and
because especially because trump has
been nominated now
four or five times for the peace prize
next year
and he was nominated also in 2018 i
believe
um and so they wanted to talk about
trump and the peace prize
and you know also you know yeah with the
election coming up
um and so i did not
say at all that i thought he was a
worthy peace champion
um but he does fulfill you know some of
the criteria
in alfred nobel's last will so he has
you know uh in through agreements and
economic agreements and also other you
must
brought countries closer together and so
he has
filled and that he has done in the in
the previous year so there's a previous
year criteria
that actually the the noble committee
doesn't
usually look so much at so he does
you know he definitely um he fulfills
that criteria he has done some
obviously i mean he has done some good
things too so i think it's it's fair to
give credit where credit is
is due right but um what i said to the
journalists in the new york post is that
i don't believe that alfred nobel would
have
chosen a person like donald trump
not because he hasn't done some good
things but because his whole persona
and rhetoric is more divisive
than it is unifying and i think we see
that also like within the united states
um
you know riots and um
and protesting and uh you know things
going on there
not only due to covet but just in sort
of a general sense of of
anger and um distrust um
and i'm not saying that this is all his
fault i think there's it's a it's a long
line of things that i think there's a
long
uh an ongoing why you know i think
people voted for trump because of a lot
of
because they lack trust in the political
elite
and in the
in the in the leaders that we've had
previously so there's something that has
to be done there
um so that people
the general population feels that they
have uh have a chance at life that they
actually can get out of poverty that
they are you know
given just you know just um
wages that are that you can live on you
know and
um so so there is i think there's a lot
of discontent
underlying all that that creates this
division as well and also
make people uh vote for someone like
donald trump who
has a very splitting and divisive
rhetoric
and donald trump also has created a lot
of you know
so well yeah conflict with with other
countries
you know with china with you know
there's so so there
are um and also i mean i don't think
there's one
european government that is in favor of
donald trump
they're they're all you know he's a very
sort of hated political figure
in europe um so
so i think he doesn't have that sort of
unifying
uh care you know manner and way of being
as barack obama had you know so
so uh so but of course you can't give
somebody the nobel peace prize
just by being a unifying person you know
you have to actually take some steps and
do something too
right and you point out in the article
or at least you're quoted in the article
as
speaking in favor of the fact that he
did accomplish something that had been
impossible for
you know decades the abraham accords in
the middle east
israel features very prominently in the
book which as a
as a jew as someone with attachment to
israel i found very fascinating
and and i think you have a tremendous
amount of courage to write a book like
this
um here's what the cover will look like
so you haven't seen it but uh
i'll show it there there's betraying the
nobel um and it has a forward by
professor michael nobel
and we both know there are these rumors
that you know alfred nobel
his wife was seduced by a mathematician
and
that's why there's no no nobel prize in
mathematics that's of course nonsense he
wasn't even married
but he did have brothers and his
brothers had children and grandchildren
and they are still possessing the nobel
name
the question is they do not seem to
agree
except in the sciences mostly with the
direction that the nobel prize
committees have taken
their namesake prize in other words the
nobel peace prize in particular
and the nobel prize in economics quote
unquote the alfred the
swedish central bank prize in honor of
alfred nobel as it's technically known
uh they've been very outspoken about
that his uh these would be his great
nephews i suppose
um talk to us about the forward written
by professor michael nobel in your book
what is his attitude towards what the
nobel prize has become
and how has it strayed from what his
great uncle would have wanted
yeah that's a you know it's i've had a
sort of a long friendship now with uh
michael nobel and i'm really honored to
call him a friend and he's helped me
tremendously
with with my book because when i brought
my project to him and my research
and i you know i didn't want to i didn't
you know like i wanted to know
what he as a member of the nobel family
and
and also he has been quite outspoken
about
in particular the peace prize and uh his
has written
articles in norwegian newspapers and and
you know he's
he's very he really cares deeply for the
cause of peace and also for the legacy
of his
um of his uh ancestor you know of his
you know great
great grand uncle or something
how do you call it well you know you
know he really cares about the legacy
legacy
and that alfred nobel really wanted to
create a better world
that was his that was his gold goal so
he
um he wanted to um
also all his inventions offered about
all his adventures where
were really for the betterment of the
world you know dynamite
which would you know is also dangerous
and can be used for you know
lethal you know means and war but
it was really meant to uh for
infrastructure
to um you know for you know tunnels
building railroads and it was
so it's you know he's he really wanted
to create an and
just a better and easier uh world for
people
and so and everywhere so he wanted his
in in in michael nobel's
view and what i've you know everything
that i've read and understood
is that all his pieces all his prices
um in the different you know the science
prizes as well
and we've spoken about this as well
brian that you know we really believe
that that alfred nobel wanted to create
a better world through
all of us you know and ultimately more
stable and peaceful world
through all of his prices so
yeah and that also makes it so um
almost devastating and really sad that
um the nobel peace prize committee
will just you know the five people that
will just sit there and just ignore
alfred nobel's intentions and also
legal document which states this right
and they will just ignore it and just
give it to the give it to people and and
and causes that they deem
are you know you know oh we believe this
is a good cause and
we'll call it peace this year you know
yeah and and
michael points out in the forward to
your to your lovely book he points out
he says
this prize the peace prize in particular
was
called the prize in fact sometimes i'll
give a talk
and the uh and the host you know of my
talk or perhaps i'll be on radio or
something like that
and the host will call it you know
losing the nobel peace prize in other
words it's almost like
the nobel peace prize is the prize as
michael states now you're a lawyer and i
want you to turn your keen
legal mind to the question of if alfred
nobel's ghost came to you
and said uni i need you to take a case
the nobel prize that i endowed to make
the world a better place
has gone to terrorists has gone to war
mongers has gone to people that
increased the number of standing armies
on planet earth
what would you do would you take that
case uni i would
i definitely would and because i mean he
was very clear i mean
it's not a detailed document his last
will as you know
but there were some criteria there and
uh you know alfred nobel we wanted um
he wanted uh
his you know there were really four
elements uh to his last will
um in regards to the peace prize
he wanted his the the winners to be
champions of peace he wanted them to
work for
brotherhood between nations the
abolition or reduction of armies
and to hold peace congresses peace
congresses can be any sort of large you
know
meeting or you know getting people you
know unifying people together and
you know and so so
so um and when
um so and that is a legal document a lot
you know a
a well last will and testament is a
legal document so
as an attorney i would say well
if you have a legal document that tells
you
that every year you give money to
um to this cost let's say to
um to uh find a cure for cancer
right then you cannot give that
that money to allocate it to uh
to for for covid for example you cannot
because it's supposed to go for
cancer research so unless there is
no more cancer in this world and then
you know with
the foundation you can agree on okay
well let's let's
decide what we should give the money to
then you know next
because there's no more cancer then you
can give it to you know to
to to fight kobe but you know that
that is what a legal document is and
so there is a responsibility uh
that the nobel foundation has in
stockholm
they actually sit with the legal
responsibility to supervise
what the different nobel committees do
with the prize
and to and to sort of
agree on it you know like at least you
know at the very least come up with a
set of
guidelines you know okay what you know
what can we include in this price and
what can we not include in this price
so there's you know there's definitely
some issues of
is this is this really legal what
they're doing
so you take the case that sounds good i
would definitely take the case being
very good confident legal hands with you
at the helm um i want to talk now about
uh the issue of nominations so
i i mentioned this in my book losing the
nobel prize
but only in the context of why the
secrecy period is so
long for the physics prizes and the
chemistry prizes etc that
when i made a nomination in 2016 uh i
was only told a few different things
one was that i couldn't nominate myself
so that you know reduce the
number of deserving candidates from you
know a million to
999 999 but
uh but nevertheless i wasn't really
given that much guidance
uh in fact i when i received the letter
inviting me to nominate
it basically said that it could be for
something given discovered or invented
decades earlier in contra distinction to
what alfred nobel's will
explicitly says in the previous year it
also said it could be given to
multiple people which he did not uh uh
explicitly say
in his in his last will and then it said
for the betterment of mankind
which is the kind of heterodox component
of the nobel
prize in physics that makes it kind of
like the nobel prize peace prize in that
it's attempting to make the world better
and in that sense imitate the peace
prize it's clear to me
that the peace prize is closest to his
heart now given that
they don't really control you know who
nominates beyond a certain level they
can
send it out to their to their networks
and and try to encourage perhaps
specific fields but the nobel peace
prize is open to anybody anybody can
nominate the winners of the peace prizes
i understand
it could have hundreds or thousands of
winners uh you talk in the book about a
couple of egregious examples not only of
of winners of the nobel peace prize
ranging from terrorists like
arafat uh to uh to to other people but
also
nomination nominated parties like hitler
mussolini and stalin now yeah um
can we really blame the peace prize
committees themselves
for who gets nominated again trump was
nominated i'm no way comparing him to
uh those horrible individuals but but
the lot is made of oh so-and-so is
nominated for the prize
in physics we don't know who's nominated
for the prize for 50 years which is
another story
but um but can we blame them for who
gets nominated it's not their fault
no well absolutely that's a great point
we cannot blame uh the committee for who
gets nominated
what i do think would help restore
trust in the noble you know peace prize
as an as an institution as a beacon of
hope
you know an inspiration for people is if
they would make the nomination
process public why why this secrecy
it's not compatible with our world that
we have today
maybe it was 100 years ago but not
anymore
so why just you know make it make it
public
and make and also um make it public who
nominates
and what their reasons were so that we
can actually and then
also then people could step up some you
know people who know
something about this candidate can step
up and get to voice their opinion
so that the research so we know that the
committee actually
does proper and gets all the information
there is right about
a certain candidates and this i think i
believe would just
make it easier for the committee and uh
also um make it easier for us to
understand oh well okay so this year i
understand because they only had to
choose between
sort of these 10 people that were
actually really
worthy candidates so we kind of get it
like why they would pick you know you
know as it is today we really don't know
and the only reason we know that that
trump
was is nominated for next year is
because
the nominators have gone public and and
told the press
right otherwise we wouldn't know so it's
not funny
yeah no that's true and then they you
know they i send you this document that
says confidential across the top and i'm
like well
not that many people read my book so
it's effectively confidential
that i was a nominator um why something
i've always been curious about why is
the alfred nobel was swedish
and with some russian um extraction why
is the peace prize given out in norway
yeah it's the only one of his prizes
that was
given uh to norway and it's quite
curious we
we actually don't know why so this you
know
but what i've you know i've discussed
this with with sort of experts in
history on
and and also with michael nobel and um
what the conclusion you know we come to
it is that it was really
back then um norway was part of sweden
we were actually governed by sweden so
norway did not have its
own military power it was very sort of
it was the little brother with uh with
no power
so and also the norwegian government
that was there was a government but it
was
you know ruled by the swedish you know
king and government
they were um really they had a great
they showed a great interest
in uh in the the sort of
the costs you know in in peace so they
um
favored you know they were one of the
first you know sort of government
governments to
uh to publicly favor arbitration
as a means to um to to resolve conflict
between countries
um they also um
gave money to peace congresses so they
were sort of an
early you showed very early on an
interest in the cause
and um sweden at the time was the most
powerful
of the scandinavian countries at least
so it was you know sort of a
a little bit of a powerhouse and with
with strong links
to the french um you know uh to the
french
kings you know and sort of royalties and
you know they had
very strong ties with with european
countries so
nori was then the more the innocent
little brother um
and we believe that after nobel wanted
to give you know wanted such a place
to avoid you know this this whole thing
becoming so
political and part of a power struggle
right so yeah that's interesting even
even the process itself
of the nobel prize is political uh not
only the prizes that get uh awarded or
the selected uh parties who win it
yeah we think of um we think of norway
here in america
as um as sweden's canada
uh no i'm just kidding we're not uh but
it's it's true
we do too so um i want to ask you
a question that i've often thought about
in physics there have been multiple
examples
uh in chemistry of of prize winners
that did great harm by virtue of the
fact that they
had been written into the history books
for all times as one of the 230 or so
mostly men by that you know when i wrote
my book there was only two women there
had been only two women the previous one
maria mayer had had won since 1963.
now thankfully after my book they've
doubled the number of female nobel prize
winners
uh but um but you know it's such a small
cohort and there have been some horrible
behavior or some say you know borderline
unconscionable behavior
by winners i'm thinking of william
shockley who invented the transistor won
the nobel prize
for that in the 50s and 60s uh and
the question about his nobel prize
getting revoked
because he had advocated for essentially
what we call eugenics
uh has come up uh similarly you know jim
watson
a co-discoverer along with rosalind
franklin and others of
of the dna double helix structure um has
said some things that are quite
offensive in many quarters um what do
you
make of the fact that uh there have been
no nobel prizes revoked
for physics prizes at least has that
ever happened
in the peace prize and would it be
beneficial if they did revoke some of
the past
egregious sinners there have
never been a prize that's been revoked
by the peace prize committee either and
um i actually find that quite shocking
because of course the committee cannot
know what a candidate will
turn into right after after they've
given someone the price i mean they can
always hope
but when um the most egregious example
that comes to mind is really
the the you know leader of of uh myanmar
you know um uh ayinsan
suki who's who's
really you know allowing genocide to
happen
in her own country and um and she was
she was definitely a worthy winner
back in 1991 when she won when she was a
political prisoner
um and for you know for the cause of
democracy that she but
all the things that she stood for back
then
has now it's it's no longer valid
because of
the atrocities that is going that are
going on in her own country
under her watch so and the fact that
she's also
having a trial for the the
the international court of justice in
the hague and it's ongoing
so she is probably going to go away from
war crimes
and do we really want to have a war
crime
criminal as a nobel peace prize laureate
i don't think so and i don't think it's
it's it's honoring
other laureates i don't think it's
honoring alfred nobel's
intentions either for the prize so i
think it would serve the committee and
serve the peace prize
to be able to revoke and that's just
their decision they can
absolutely there's nothing saying that
they cannot revoke it so why won't they
do it
you know right it's very strange to me
exactly i feel like it's the same reason
they won't recognize people who clearly
deserve the prize in physics
uh like jocelyn bell for example they
could nominate they could give her a
nobel prize tomorrow
but they don't do it and i speculate in
my book because it's essentially the
world's biggest monopoly of its kind
at least in physics and i think in the
peace prize maybe even more so but just
as we can't blame them
for who is nominated uh we can blame
them the the corollaries that we
certainly can name them
for not or you know or shame them or
blame them
for not uh revoking prizes that have
been uh used to bolster the image of
of criminals in some cases as you
pointed out
and so i think it's uh it's it's not
done
in other words they don't do it at their
peril i believe
yeah in my book i wrote about how the
pulitzer prize used to be more
prestigious in some sense
than the nobel prizes at least in
literature say but now
of course the opposite is true and the
question is
you know what can we do if you were uh
if you were if it was the you know given
to you uni has the
sole discretion over the next peace
prize do you have a clear
winner that you would recommend do you
have a standard of rubric
i mean maybe it'll be helpful someday if
you and i we talk about what should be
like
the the classification that allows a
person to be
to be selected as a laureate and then
what allows them to be revoked if they
don't behave properly
but what is your what would be sort of a
good
prize in in your opinion
so i think there are i mean there are
there are many people
that would deserve the prize i think i
think in general
i think someone who perhaps is not
already a state
leader somebody who doesn't have the
platform
to operate from and and the financial
means
so if i think it takes courage
definitely to um select someone who's
maybe not as
known um who is uh
who is who is you know who's not a
celebrity because that's another thing
too
brian is that you know they love these
celebrities and when they are
when they are pushed you know like when
other celebrities and state leaders
they're
pushing for a candidate you know over
time
the committee tends to sort of give in
because okay look we'll just give it to
them you know like you know
because because they've been you know
harassing us for so long you know about
this price and
i believe that that's not benefiting the
price and
increasing trust either so to have the
courage
to really um select
winners that are doing a lot
and would definitely need the celebrity
and the financial means and the platform
that is given
through the prize would be would be
beneficial
so um there's uh
i think they're i think they're just up
uh off the top of my head
um there's there's actually a woman in
the united states and she's been
uh a peace champion really for years
um she's quite moderate you know so
she's not
the taste of everyone but her name is
her name is cora weiss
and i believe she lives in new york and
she has you know um
she was you know one of the first you
know to really stand up against
the vietnam uh war back in those days
and she's just continued
and her her whole philosophy
and also teaching she's been teaching in
schools
and teaching you know uh students about
you know the sort of the foundations for
peace you know to create you know for
relationships to be the
the basis for communication and basis
for negotiation
right between people and countries so
she has done a great deal and she's
written books and she's
and she's been nominated numer numerous
times and she's
she's on the radar uh of the committee
but they've
never given it to her and i'm guessing
is because she
she doesn't serve any um any political
uh you know she doesn't you know she's
not serving any sort of
norwegian foreign policy you know they
have nothing to gain from her
and uh she's not really a celebrity and
uh
so there would be no sort of you know
and there's there's no controversy
either you know because she's she's
pretty much only done good things right
so right
so um but people like that like normal
regular people
who are making you know these amazing
efforts
you know yeah and can really do some
good
so i want to close with uh because i
know you've got a very tight time
schedule with the book coming out in
just a few hours
um what do you think the nobel prize uh
matters to people why is it so
um so sought after wise i mean the
president of the united states you know
will tweet about
this prize and meanwhile you know
there's probably
a lot of these people without platforms
or even those that have won the prize
that would gladly trade that prize for
the power that a president wields
so why is that why is it so uh obsessed
over
and why is it important if you believe
it still is important
i believe it is important uh especially
today
seeing um with with you know the
i think our countries i mean not
in my lifetime anyway but i can't i
can't recall a time in history
in recent history where the our world
has been more
divided you know after world war ii
obviously
um you know we see these riots and
discontent
in general in our society not only in
the united states but here too
and you know massive problems with with
immigration and what you know what to do
and uh i believe um the peace prize
it comes back to leadership and for the
peace prize to be
what alfred nobel really wanted it to be
to be
a beacon of hope and inspiration to all
of us not only to leaders but to all of
us
as individuals to become the peace
champions we can be
in our own you know worlds in our own
societies in in our families in our you
know in our schools and
at our jobs and um
and so and so but if we don't trust
you know if we if we don't have trust in
the institution
and in the committee making these good
choices
for us of course we don't trust the
laureates either we don't trust these
winners you know because like oh but
that person has done
you know that person has literally
blended blood on our hands and
you know how can we you know we don't we
don't look up to these people anymore
and so um which is really sad and i
think it's
you know i think they they
if they could be brave enough to um
really choose leaders that are unifying
that stand for connection
unity and peace and you know through you
know and and the science crisis the same
thing right through
innovative um innovative means
you know and science and just um
then it is then we are then at least
there's hope that we can get on
back on track and that's where i think
the peace prize has a role to play
in giving us these role models that we
can actually look up to
when we don't necessarily have these
role models in our governments
and in our corporations for for that
matter that's right so that's really
where i think the
you know the it's it's important to
restore meaning
honor and integrity really and that's
right
i agree completely i see alfred nobel as
kind of this
visionary genius who had uh all the
right motivations and yet would uh
surely be turning in his grave
or ashes i think he requested to be
cremated but i want to close because you
make him human in this book
with all these wonderful quotes and and
he really comes across in a sort of a
more tender
uh like than i'd ever really envisioned
him and so i credit you for
for turning me on to that perspective of
him and uh i want to begin with or just
end with the quote that i'm going to
start
off and i'm going to record an intro to
it but uh i'll record this uh later
but he said uh in the quote you have a
quote from him in every chapter i love
it
you say that he says i am a misanthrope
and yet
utterly benevolent have more than one
screw loose
yet i am super idealist who digests
philosophy
more efficiently than food i assume that
if you and alfred nobel could get
together it would be a wonderful
conversation i would love to be a fly on
the wall
for that uh but for now i want to wish
you the best of success with this
wonderful book betraying the nobel
which is really a cry for for
reformation to use the prizes prestige
while it still has it
to do good for the world as alfred
intended so uh uni i want to thank you
so much i'm looking forward to doing a
few events with you coming up i'll put
those on my website and we'll tweet
about them
have a wonderful day enjoy the ride
congratulations on another spectacular
book
thank you so much brian it's wonderful
to speak to you thank you thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible with professor brian keating
please subscribe comment share and
review
watch on youtube listen on itunes
spotify google player stitcher
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information and to sign up for
professor keating's mailing list
go to dr briankeeting.com
that's dr bryantheating.com
follow professor keating on medium and
twitter at
dr brian heating d r bryant eating
for more information on the clark center
go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
at the university of california san
diego in the division of physical
sciences
eric very director brian keating
co-director
produced by brian keating and stuart
valco